so it turns out the nose wasn't wrong
when he declared that there would be no
resurrections this time for Loki still
that doesn't mean much where Infinity
stones and trickster gods are concerned
Loki manages something in endgame with
potentially huge ramifications spoilers
from here on out quick recap when the
Avengers go back in time to get the
Infinity stones an endgame
one team heads to start our just after
the team have captured Loki and Avengers
in part because of the interference of
the Avengers from the future the captive
Loki gets his hands on the tesseract and
disappears in a blue flash the big
question is where did he go the most
immediate concern about Loki is whether
or not he creates an alternate timeline
splits off from the main MCU continuity
in which he escapes the Avengers with
the tesseract when Captain America
brings all the stones back to their
respective times does he return
everything to normal and stop anytime
lines from branching or is Loki still
out there with the 2012 tesseract if
Loki does create an alternate timeline
when he escapes and it still exists and
that opens a whole world of
possibilities free from the Avengers and
in possession of the space stone there's
no limit to where Loki might go he might
bring the tesseract to his benefactor
Thanos the mad Titans emissary the other
makes it perfectly clear what Loki risks
if he fails Sano's and none of its
pleasant
no crevice where you can thank you with
the Chitauri forces Santos gave to Loki
destroyed the god of mischief might see
getting the tesseract back to the Titan
as the only way to save his life however
a Thanos probably wouldn't be Loki's
first stop losing the Chitauri forces to
the Avengers would not necessarily sign
Loki's death warrant
but there's something we know now that
we didn't know when Avengers was
released that Thanos gave Loki and
infinity stone to get an infinity stone
he trusted the mine stone to Loki and an
endgame Loki leaves it behind when he
escapes how does it help follows his
plans if he gains one stone just to lose
another unless Loki is
uncharacteristically foolish he won't
run to Thanos doing so would get his
neck broken six years early whatever
deal was struck between Thanos and Loki
it all happens off screen we don't know
the extent of Loki's knowledge regarding
Thanos his plans and his other allies
when Thor confronts Loki and Avengers
Loki tells his brother he knows all
about the tesseract I have grown Odinson
in my exile I have seen the true power
of the tesseract so unless he's lying he
knows quite a bit if we assume by 2012
that Thanos and Ronan the accuser are
already allies and a Loki knows by the
Alliance
Ronan could be Loki's first stop at that
point Ronan is a no position to
challenge son owes and that's because he
doesn't know what Thanos is after and
Thanos tests the Kree with capturing the
orb Ronan doesn't know if it contains
the Power Stone if Loki knows more about
Thanos his machinations and Ronan then
he has much to offer the Kree warlord
and the potential ally to protect him
from Thanos his wrath in the now classic
mid-credits scene of Avengers when
Thanos has first revealed the other is
warning the mad Titan against any
further action on earth he tells his
master that to challenge earth is to
court death if Loki guesses at this
apprehension on the part of Thanos his
underlings to mess with earth then the
trickster might decide the best place to
be is right on earth as long as he stays
under the radar of the Avengers he could
remain on earth for as long as he wants
with his own superhero enemies acting as
a shield against Thanos his wrath or
alternatively he could stay on earth or
the intention of recapturing his sceptre
to give it to Thanos Loki probably knows
if he returns to Thanos without both
Infinity stones the mad Titan will do a
lot worse to him than the Hulk ever
would
in 2012
Loki's greatest weakness is his passion
for revenge with an infinity stone at
his command and his knowledge of the
secret ways into and out of Asgard his
first trip after endgame it might be
back home to claim what he sees as its
rightful throne in the proper MCU
timeline he doesn't have to worry about
the nose
Loki's failure to conquer earth that
leads him straight to an Asgardian
dungeon
as soon as he escapes in Thor the dark
world he fakes his own death and
disguises himself as Odin the disguise
allows him to rule Asgard yes but it has
the added bonus of hiding him from
Thanos what's easier than conquering a
world ruled by your adoptive family
conquering a world ruled by no one of
course after 2011 slor we don't hear
much from Jotunheim the land of the
frost giants Thor and Malekith visit
briefly and involuntarily during their
battle in 2013's Thor the dark world but
we don't exactly get a good picture of
the political situation there we know
after initially offering to help
assassinate odin loki portrays a murders
his biological father and then he
attempts to use the Bifrost to destroy
the frost giants world it was just a bit
of fun raining
so when Loki escapes the Avengers an
endgame and needs a place to hang his
haunt at a potentially lead Alessio
tunheim it might be the perfect choice
and the throne could be his for the
taking he is the biological son of their
dead king and he has an infinity stone
to back up his claim not to mention that
with intimate knowledge of Asgard and
his most powerful leaders he's in a
unique position to satisfy any frost
giants hungry to make war on Odin once
more the mid-credits scene of Thor the
dark world sees sip and Volstagg sent to
nowhere to deliver the ether Thor the
collector is one of the most deceptively
important moments in the MCU because of
this line the tesseract is already on
Asgard there's not wise to keep two
Infinity stones so close together
without some as of yet unrevealed
connection between Loki and the
collector it's a moment that doesn't
make much sense
it's Loki disguised as Odin who sends
the ether to nowhere and a power-hungry
Loki is not someone we expect to send an
infinity stone to someone else
not unless there's a plan behind it or a
connection between the collector and
Loki could also explain the grandmasters
friendship with the trickster in thor
ragnarok as Grandmaster and the
collector of brothers if this connection
between the collector and Loki
ever proves to be more than speculation
then it could be that nowhere was Loki's
first up after endgame although granted
that's one of the least likely outcomes
one thing that's easy to forget about
Loki is that before Thanos finally
rounds them up in Avengers infinity war
Loki has more encounters with more
Infinity stones than anyone in the MCU
in Avengers he possesses both the mine
stone and the tesseract after usurping
Odin at the end of Thor the dark world
he has access to the reality stone until
he sends it to nowhere and has as much
access as he once to the space stone
Loki knows you Infinity stones at least
he knows something about them we don't
know how much if anything Stannis tells
him about them but the trickster god is
a way of getting information whether you
want him to or not armed with the
Infinity stone that's the power to bring
him anywhere
Loki may decide to go on an infinity
stone quest of his own not only with the
completion of such an endeavor feed his
hunger for power but again would provide
him with the muscle to destroy Thanos
should the Titan come for his vengeance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
Avengers endgame are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]